[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat depuis à plusieurs
mois des caravanes de gens du voyage se
sont installées illégalement dans une
zone commerciale de maurepas une
situation qui relance le débat sur
l'accueil de cette communauté a sur
notre territoire est des infrastructures
existent mais les aires de grands
passages prévus par la loi se font
attendre
gens du voyage comment cohabiter dans
les yvelines c'est le débat du jour pour
y répondre guégot grégory gary astier
sur ce plateau d'on soir à francfort
vous êtes maire de maurepas également un
vice président de saint quentin en
yvelines en face de vous françois go
bref ce qui est bon ce soir vous êtes
membre de l'association gens du voyage
en yvelines en charge notamment des
questions liées à l'habitat et à
l'urbanisme est juste à côté de vous
etienne pour dans des soies en fait
également en manque de cette association
et accompagnateur social auprès des
familles merci à tous les trois d'avoir
répondu présent ce soir et alors grégory
garcia je me tourne tout d'abord vers
vous donc il ya quelques semaines vous
avez envoyé un communiqué de presse aux
médias ou pour partager
j'aimerais dire votre album on peut le
dire comme ça sur les installations des
gens du voyage à paris ouest aujourd'hui
quelle est la situation la situation
elle est toujours aussi dramatique
puisque on a encore des occupations
illicites de terrain qui sont dans la
zone d'activités paris-ouest je rappelle
que c'est le deuxième pôle majeur
économique de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et que là je sors
tout juste d'ailleurs d'une réunion avec
l'état et l'ensemble des exploitants des
commerçants concernés également le
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et
coignières qui étaient aussi concernées
par ces occupations illicites pour faire
un point et demander à l'état que tout
simplement que l'état applique la loi
c'est à dire de faire expulser les gens
du voyage qui occupent illégalement des
terrains parce qu'aujourd'hui je
rappelle que ça dure depuis le mois de
septembre que nous avons un peu moins de
trente cinq caravanes installées sur le
territoire de mort par balle d'ailleurs
sur voilà exactement 35 sur la vie de de
coignières et qu'aujourd'hui ça n'en
finit plus puisque les propriétaires
sont des propriétaires différents selon
les parcelles
donc il faut qu'ils engagent des actions
judiciaires vous en tant que maire vous
ne pouvez pas en fait engagé de présence
le propriétaire de chaque parcelle qui
peut engager une action en justice
or aujourd'hui une nouvelle loi vient
d'arriver à la date du 7 novembre 2018
qui permet de simplifier les procédures
aujourd'hui j'ai un arrêté que j'ai
signé en septembre 2014 pour interdire
l'occupation des du territoire communal
privés ou publics en dehors de l'art
d'accueil qui est prévu parce que je
rappelle que mort pas rempli ses
obligations d'accueil des gens du voyage
on à vingt-et-une place pour les non
sédentaires et on a d'autres placent
également donc un peu moins de 50 ans
tout donc on rempli nos obligations
sauf que aujourd'hui il ya un arrêté qui
interdit ses occupations et la nouvelle
loi de novembre 2010 8 permet d'engager
tout de suite les forces de l'ordre avec
l'avis du préfet pour expulser ses
occupations illégales et là les
commerçants n'en peuvent plus on est
pour certains un moins 60 % de baisse du
chiffre d'affaires on est parfois même
la limite d'un plan de licenciement donc
on est dans une situation en effet
catastrophique donc là on a demandé
l'aide de l'état vraiment qu'elle fasse
tout simplement respecter la loi
une réaction par rapport à la situation
à laquelle est confrontée confronté le
cigarettier
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que la
situation se répète que d'année en année
on compte les mêmes situations
donc on a une espèce de connaissance des
besoins qui sont pas satisfaits
donc si si il faut créer des aides et
des places supplémentaires il faut tenir
compte de ses occupations
voilà donc ça veut dire qu'il ya un
déséquilibre entre l'offre actuelle ce
qui a dans le schéma départemental
est ce qu'il faut faire un rat
d'ailleurs dans quelques semaines est ce
que vous comprenez l'exaspération
c'est sûr c'est sûr mais il faut aussi
comprendre les familles qui sont qui
sont tenus fac et autres se sont tous
trouvés dans la situation de ce matin à
son endroit là parce qu'il avait pas
d'autre endroit où se mettre alors une
précision pour les téléspectateurs
l'accueil donc et l'habitat des gens du
voyage et réglementaires principalement
par la loi du 5 juillet 2000 la loi
prévoit l'élaboration donc vous en
parliez d'un schéma départemental pour
l'accueil et l'habitat des gens du
voyage un schéma d'ailleurs qui est
révisé tous les six ans les communes de
plus de 5000 habitants également doivent
contribuer à l'arrêt la réalisation
d'une aire d'accueil vous le disiez
monsieur qu'à rester c'est le cas à
maurepas donc depuis à 2012 je crois
alors juste et mon corps quand ça
fonctionne ces aires d'accueil
alors aujourd'hui la compétence avait
délégué à l'intercommunalité c'est saint
quentin en yvelines qui gère la création
et l'aménagement des aires d'accueil des
gens du voyage
sauf que le pouvoir de police il reste
au maire est donc évidemment le
territoire de 50 ans domine pour le
moment ne remplit pas ses obligations
mais vous parliez de la loi juste titre
de 2000 elle vient tout juste d'être
modifiée par une dernière loi de
novembre début 2018 qui est d'ailleurs
réussi à mettre d'accord l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat pour permettre aux
mères d'effectuer tout de suite des
démarches et aujourd'hui a été dissocié
dans la loi même si l'agglomération ne
remplit pas ses obligations de
construction d'aires d'accueil des gens
du voyage et je l'entends bien et vers
en effet il ya certainement un manque de
place par rapport aux besoins ça
s'éteint c'est un sujet évidemment qu'il
faut traiter mais en revanche ça n'est
que ça ne ça n'excuse pas le fait
aujourd'hui qu' on ne peut pas avoir la
force des forces de l'ordre qui évacuent
des zones qui sont je rappelle occupé
illégalement dire qu'aujourd'hui les
commerçants me disais tout à l'heure il
se branche sur les bornes électriques
sur l'eau il occupe des parkings de
manière illégale
voilà il ya toute sorte de gêne aussi
pour pour les commerçants et donc il
faut aussi entendre ça et donc moi en
tant que maire de maurepas je ne peux
pas être responsable du fait qu'il
manque des aires d'accueil ailleurs en
france et sur le territoire même des
yvelines
et de pénaliser l'activité économique en
plus je rappelle quand même dans un
climat national assez tendues avec les
gilet jaune et qu'aujourd'hui vient se
rajouter ce phénomène où on constate
vraiment l'impuissance de l'état à ne
pas vouloir régler ces problèmes parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est facile il suffit
que le préfet demande aux forces de
l'ordre de faire évacuer sur ces aires
d'accueil
est-ce que selon vous où elles sont
suffisamment adapté aux gens du voyage
en l'état alors nous qu'on a eu un
regard sur la longue durée est depuis
toujours les qu'on essaie de faire
valoir qu' il ya beaucoup de voyageurs
de familles qui ont besoin d'avoir un
chez eux
voilà les pouvoirs publics ont toujours
répondu en disant on va d'abord
s'occuper de ce qui bouge
les itinérants du moment où ils bougent
et donc on a beaucoup dans grand
couronne d'île de france
particulièrement
il n'y a pas que les yvelines on a
beaucoup de familles qui sont des
itinérants forcées et qu'ils aimeraient
bien on va et et faire partie de la
ville je n'ai pas fait refaire qu'on lui
force à aller dans word et donc quand on
a fait des aires d'accueil pour eux
c'était déjà un poumon une possibilité
de se poser quelque part mais si on
avait su que c'était cela qui
viendraient ceux qui cherchent à se
poser c'est pas ça qu'on aurait fait et
donc il ya une espèce de mécompréhension
sur les priorités sur la manière dont
les gens finalement préféré avoir un
chez eux plutôt que bouger tout le temps
et donc il ya en répandant plus vite et
dans l'urgence on n'a pas bien on n'a
pas pris les choses dans le bon sens
donc c'est la position des associations
au niveau national au niveau de 50 on y
vient en tout cas en 2016 ont dénombré
s5 aire d'accueil de terrains familiaux
étienne brodeur vous pouvez juste
préciser ce que c'est ce que sont des
terrains familiaux les terrains
familiaux c'est justement lorsque les
personnes veulent d'avoir un terrain sur
lequel qui leur est attribué à dire ils
peuvent rester sur le long terme de
moins en moins de voyageurs sans
itinérant géré par régulièrement dans
leur vie dans l'année la plupart du
temps ils restent 10èmes rester un
endroit premièrement parce que le
travail est difficile à trouver en code
rouge
il est plus difficile le travail est
rare on voit bien la situation pour les
personnes qui ont des métiers qui sont
souvent modestes donc trouver le temps
un travail à proximité dans un terrain
qu'en fin une zone qu'on connaît c'est
plus facile donc ça c'est une une des
raisons pour lesquelles on reste sur
place qu'une la deuxième raison c'est
aussi une raison scolaire et après il ya
aussi des familles qui aime bien se
retrouver et puissent se consolider donc
ça ça veut dire que les personnes aiment
bien quitter la halle aire d'accueil des
gens du voyage pour avoir quelque chose
qui est chez eux c'est ça le vrai besoin
il ya un deuxième problème c'est que
l'air d'accueil des gens du voyage pour
les gens de voyage eux-mêmes c'est
quelque chose qui est cher quand on
compare par exemple très simple d'accès
sont déserts qui sont payantes
il faut qu'il y ait une redevance
journalière j'imagine donc en fait ouais
c'est l'ambition de 50 voilà donc la
conversion fixe des prix qui sont ben
voilà c'est ce qu'ils sont mais faute
pour savoir enfin pour avoir une idée
sans entrer trop dans le détail on peut
aller dans le détail mais je pense qu'on
va rester la seule et grande barbe pour
une famille le coût de l'habitat sur une
aire d'accueil
c'est à peu près 300 à 400 euros suivant
été hiver suivant le coup électrique et
donc par mois et là-dessus à cela il
faut rajouter le coût de la caravane
qu'on doit acheter et qui est à
rembourser peut-être dans l'ordre de 500
euros par moi aussi donc ça fait 900
euros et là dessus il ya aucune aide
il n'y a pas d'appel etc donc c'est
quand même quelqu'un investissement
c'est vraiment très très très onéreux et
en rapport avec un appartement
voilà quelqu'un qui a une économie très
modestes comme faille pour une fabriquer
une économie très modestes comme ceux
des gens du voyage en appartement on
bénéficierait de la paix elle va ce
serait quelques centaines d'euros mais
loin de ça dont je vous fait si le pin
gris selon vous du coup ça veut dire
qu'en fait voilà plus les aires
d'accueil sont chères plus les familles
ont envie d'aller habiter dans un
endroit qui est qui et moins onéreux
dans lequel ils arrivent à survivre
parce qu'en fait quand c'est cher eh ben
les familles
sans mise à mort enfin ça laisse à les
écarts de la vie voilà c'est une
conséquence
alors évidemment je comprends bien que
l'air d'accueil il faut caler son
économie propre mais l'air d'accueil
avec quelque chose de cher donc faut le
savoir il ya des l'aja j'ai demandé
juste sur sur 3 loin parce que j'avais
je rencontrais des gens qui étaient sur
trame il ya quelques jours on m'a dit
mais reste des places à trappes
aujourd'hui j'ai vu d'autres personnes
qui ont dit ah ça vient d'être pris donc
les gens viennent en fait ils passent
mais c'est vrai qu' ils hésitent alors
je vaux je vois des oeuvres il ya des
places libres
donc ça veut dire que enfin j'ai connu
de ces deux familles pas celle de qui
seront sur votre ville à paris ouest
mais d'autres familles qui disait ben
oui mais c'est trop cher donc nous on va
ailleurs
alors alors qu'ils connaissent bien les
accueille 1 qui vont à rambouillet tout
autant qu'ils vont à elancourt aussi
temps au temps et puis là qui sont qui
m'a dit on va ailleurs parce que c'est
cher donc faut voir ça cette économie là
je vous parlais du coup pour les gens du
voyage le coup maintenant pour une
commune combien ça coûte de de
construire une aire d'accueil
vous avez raison de tunis ce sujet là
parce que la collectivité à l'époque on
s'était construit par maurepas on
n'était pas dans l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
donc le budget quand même sur le fond
propre de la ville c'était 1,7 million
d'euros pour 21 une place donc ça il a
fallu le financer et on n'a pas d'être
non plus de l'état de subventions etc
pour financer ce type de deir d'accueil
donc voilà il faut aussi quand les
villes remplissent leurs obligations
qu'elles trouvent les fonds qu'elles
investissent qu'elle de 100 printemps
pour faire en sorte que ces habitants
qui sont comme tous les autres habitants
qu'ils ont le droit évidemment d'avoir
des terrains pour se loger en plus et
accueillir dignement
sauf que là moi j'ai beaucoup j'ai
beaucoup appris à leur contact parce que
personnellement je me suis aussi
opposées alors venu sera des terrains
publics notamment autour du centre
aquatique qui va être reconstruit ou
pendant une heure et demie j'ai je me
suis opposé j'ai négocié avec eux mêmes
dans la zone d'activités paris ouest
je me suis opposé avec d'autres
commerçants et j'ai beaucoup appris
auprès d'eux et souvent ce sont des
familles qui viennent du sud et qui
remonte au nord pour voir des amis dans
des périodes de fêtes
mais il me disait mais nous on n'a pas
de problème de place dans le sud de la
france
on vient dans le nord parce que
on a de la famille parce que ce sont les
fêtes mais puisque dans le nord de toute
façon après on en surnombre parce qu'on
remonte pour les voir voilà la famille
du coup on se retrouve dans cette
surpopulation et d'en savoir en effet
les aires d'accueil ne sont pas
suffisamment adapté une autre chose
aussi qu'ils m'ont signifié c'est qu'il
ya un manque de rotations sur les aires
d'accueil existantes et ça faut que
j'arrive à le maltraiter que
l'agglomération même si je ne suis pas
le responsable mais de voir comment
réellement sa femme chaude dans le
règlement même une finalement dans 50
ans qui ont les aires d'accueil
plus de 5000 habitants aussi mais qui
n'ont pas fait de derb accueille alors
c'est quoi c'est une question de coût
finalement ça alors ça c'est un problème
c'est s est une question de coût c'est
une question politique de volonté
politique aussi faut dire les choses et
aujourd'hui il faut regarder aussi
comment on peut peut-être travailler sur
l'existant de de sorte qu'on ne retrouve
pas aussi sans arrêt les mêmes familles
parce que moi j'ai c'est le cas sur
l'art de cueille ne démord pas ce sont
les mêmes familles qui viennent et du
coup vous empêcher la rotation de celles
qui voudraient venir
donc voilà il ya aussi cette crispation
et je les ai sentis en discutant
beaucoup avec eux parce que voilà c'est
un c'est un sujet qu'il faut prendre à
bras le corps je sais que le législateur
essayer de le faire
c'est un sujet qui est très sensible
notamment aussi on n'a pas d'aires de
grand passage en jeu 18 justement on va
justement exactement tout à fait puisque
le schéma départemental d'accueil et
d'habitat des gens du voyage 2013 2019
prévoit justement la réalisation d'au
moins deux aires de grands passages dans
les yvelines au nord et au sud
on rappelle d'ailleurs ce que c'est une
aire de grand passage oui je le faire
les gens du voyage sont des gens en
général ces religieux et l'été bien sûr
fallu t il était souvent mais
parfois toute l'année il ya des groupes
qui du groupe alors souvent plus tôt
des évangéliques qui qui se réunit ce
qui bouge
et puis qui qui se réunissent pour pour
se retrouver et à voir tout un temps
important de l'admission de prieur
ensemble c'est ça les parties du
nomadisme et puis de la culture
j'éternue de façon générale alors ça
existe aussi pour les groupes
catholiques mais qu'ils le font au moins
il ya plus de pèlerinage partant pour
les catholiques c'est plus tout ça et
puis la nage dans des lieux je parle
minimum de 150 alors par contre
voilà là quand un certain quand des
groupes qu'ils soient évangéliques ou
catholiques se déplace il faut une aire
d'accueil de grand passage et c'est une
nécessité
voilà alors juste après en yvelines
voilà nous sommes début 2019 et donc ses
aires de grands passages n'existe
toujours pas pourquoi selon vous alors
évidemment ccc l'état d'ailleurs le
préfet avait été invité en sueur sur ce
plateau
il a décliné l'invitation le préfet
aurait pu y avoir c'était cette réponse
mais est un sujet qui est extrêmement
sensible qui est dans les tiroirs depuis
de nombreuses années évidemment qu'ils
créent aussi des tensions parce que la
problématique c'est qu'un il faut
trouver le terrain et évidemment ça pose
aussi question il ya de nombreux
collectifs notamment qui qui s'élèvent
contre justement ces aires de grands
passages aussi voilà après c'est en
effet il ya des revendications ici et là
donc il faut trouver le terrain et puis
un petit qui finance parce que d'après
ce qu'on comprend aujourd'hui c'est que
ce sera pas l'état de financer mais aux
collectivités donc ça pose quand même un
problème c'est comment on trouve aussi
les moyens et puis ici on trouve les
moyens c'est 100 - ailleurs voilà il ya
cessé c'est assez compliqué aujourd'hui
je ne connais pas l'issue 2
l'implantation d'une aire de grand
passage dans nos studios normalement il
y avait le terrain de poigny la forêt
qui avait été réquisitionnée par l'état
qui fait encore débat on ne sait pas c
est encore en suspens parce que voilà
c'est un sujet qui est qui est complexe
et il faut qu'on arrive à obtenir une
majorité sur ces sujets là c'est bien il
a un côté un peu politique en fait de
prendre la décision et c'est une
décision qui forcément facile à prendre
mais il faut la prendre mais voilà
collectivement on a peut-être des soucis
pour prendre des décisions concernant un
sujet que qu'on comprend peut-être pas
très bien quand c'est pas bien et puis
qu'on met un peu de façon marginale
moi je crois qu'on a en fait une
question sur de la fête de vérité c'est
un truc pour moi c'est ça c'est il ya
des gens de voyage qui existent sur le
département où qui bouge et on le sait
c'est ce que disait tout à l'heure
françois et des gens et en fait on a du
mal à les traiter
il ya enfin il le dira mieux à conduire
les dossiers jusqu'au bout en prenant en
compte la réalité de ces personnes là
souvent on dit il arrive mais voilà on
sait qu'ils existent mais en fait on ne
va pas jusqu'au bout de la question
comme on le ferait avec un problème
c'est pourquoi mathématiques ou sociales
n'importe quoi en disant mais ça se
déclinent jusqu'au bout et au total
après on sait qu' il faut prendre la
décision et on apprend qu'il y ait les
accueils qu'il faut les aires de grand
passage
éventuellement les terrains familiaux un
certain nombre de choses mais on va pas
jusqu'au bout de ça donc pour moi il ya
une question de gérer de vérité de
rapport à la vérité des collectivités
locales d'une façon générale fait de la
préfecture je ne serai pas dire quoi
peut être aussi de l'ensemble des
citoyens dont nous et peut-être qu'on
sait pas nous nous associations
présentes et les choses aussi
peut-être bien ce qui montre que c'est
difficile c'est qu'on est obligé de
faire des lois si ça se faisait tout
seul il y aurait pas besoin et donc
l'état
j'essaye de montrer ce qui à faire les
parlements regarde et donc la loi
importante
actuellement c'est la loi égalité
citoyenneté qui dit attention maintenant
on a compris qu'il fallait faire des
terres d'accueil mais on va aussi parlé
beaucoup des terrains familiaux des
points d'ancrage
donc dans le prochain schéma
départemental ils tous les élus seront
invités à donner leur avis le
qu'administration c'est à dire voilà on
a regardé des besoins va en tenir compte
et qu'il faudra dans les programmes
d'habitat et d'urbanisme dire qu'est ce
qu'on fait donc j'ai regardé le
programme local de l'habitat de la
communauté d'agglomération il faut faire
entre 2018 et 2020 3 10 mille logements
si on faisait 0 5% à 20% de cet effort
d'habitat pour attraper les 50 années de
choses qu'on n'a pas fait le voyage on
aurait fait un progrès spectaculaire
donc c'est vrai que quand on regarde le
prix d'une ère salaire très cher quand
on regarde le prix de tous les amnesty
tous les investissements pour
l'aménagement et l'habitat
quelque chose qui qui rentrent sont
chères c'est pas soit là ça ne ruine pas
l'ensemble de la collectivité
voilà alors juste juste une autre
question il y aurait garé astier sur
l'air de grand passage puisque vous êtes
vice présidente 50 ans ne b est ce qu'il
a été question justement peut-être
qu'une aire de grand passage je passe
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines alors et la question était
posée tout à l'heure par la préfecture
quand on était au rendez vous avec
l'ensemble des partenaires économiques
qui sont concernés dans cette affaire de
cul passion de deux de leurs terrains le
président de l'agglomération réaffirmé
qu'il n'était pas question qu'il n' aire
de grand passage sur le territoire de 50
ans new line on est le premier pôle
économique de l'ouest parisien et que la
volonté s'est aussi gardé une entreprise
qui font la richesse du territoire
donc ça ça a été réaffirmée après
évidemment il ya une discussion qui peut
se porter à l'échelle des yvelines de
l'île de france mais encore faut-il que
voilà on soit aussi sollicités puisque
pour le moment
c'était en effet quelque chose qui qui
traîne depuis longtemps j'entends aussi
ici et là que il ya des terrains qui
sont un peu regardé de près par l'état
mais on n'en sait pas plus
donc on se demande si quelque part on
sait que c'est un sujet extrêmement
sensible et explosif
donc l'état j'imagine
agi avec avec douceur dans ce sujet qui
doit mettre tout le monde autour de la
table pour enfin régler ces problèmes là
après j'espère qu'en tout cas le jour où
on aura une aire d'accueil de grand
passage ça réglera aussi des problèmes
d'occupation illicite ce que mange suis
dans une position particulière en tant
que maire je défends les intérêts de ma
commune évidemment moi je demande à
l'état de faire respecter la loi
je ne dis pas que les gens du voyage ne
sont pas les bienvenus au contraire
génère d'accueil et en plus je les
accueille aussi dans une de mes écoles
pour leur éducation donc ça c'est pas le
problème
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui ils
occupent des terrains qui sont de
manière à occuper de manière illégale et
que ça nuit à l'activité économique à
l'image d'une activité c'est tout ce que
je dis après le problème plus global sur
la création d accès en effet doit être
portée plus largement l'émission touche
bientôt à sa fin on va on va bientôt
conclure est ce qu'il est possible
finalement dans les yvelines de
cohabiter avec les gens du voyage donc
là le ya le magazine 2019 saint quentin
en yvelines avant de la ville du futur
la ville du futur c'est une vie dans
laquelle il ya des gens du voyage qui
sont installés là donc il faut pas dire
on aura que des queues de la haute
technologie peut pas se débarrasser de
populations qui sont en difficulté la
ville du futur elle est comme ça quand
on regardera l'ensemble des besoins le
fait qu'il ya encore des stationnements
illicites ça veut dire qu'il faut quand
même qu'on dise qu'on a pas très tout ce
qui peut être qu'en réévalué également
les besoins parce que les besoins on va
pas les gens va pas les 10 faire
disparaître d'un coup de baguette
magique il faudrait combien d'heures
d'accueil dans les yvelines pour que
tout le monde soit satisfait j'en sais
rien ne nous fait pas de comptage on est
je me fais de comptage mai
tout à l'heure je disais il ya un
rapport à la vérité c'est de dire voilà
il ya les personnes qui sont là quoi et
puis on n'en sort pas de ce chiffre là
c'est pas combien d'heures doit faire
placer toujours pas répondu que c'est
europe répondant termes d'ancrage et par
exemple sur le son est question des
terrains familiaux des terrains
attributif voilà pour les personnes je
me dis souvent de dire oui mais ya pas
de place est différent mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya pas beaucoup de place parce que
va faire la place pour un point b tout
mais il ya quand même bien des
programmes où il ya enfin des grands
lotissements privés tiff pour des pour
des maisons qui sont qui sont faits et
sur lequel on arrive à bâtir donc
l'espace existe en fait seulement
peut-être qu'on priorise un peu trop
certaines certaines populations certains
et les sédentaires peut-être au
détriment peut-être des voyageurs qui
existe et je dis ça c'est une question
de culture
voilà et la culture elle est aussi porté
par les collectivités locales qui
doivent faire et c'est pas forcément
facile à faire accepter les uns et des
autres d'autres plus pour épauler at-il
dans les cinq ans on ferait 200 terrains
familiaux dans l'ensemble des
intercommunautés d'evelyne on aurait
déjà résolu beaucoup de problèmes et on
aura une vérité qui apparaîtrait voilà
on et puis après on peut-être qu'on
verrait qu'il faut en faire d'autres
ou qu'il faut arrêter 10 offert 250 ça
serait extraordinaire extraordinaire
moi je n'ai pas de réponse aux besoins
au nombre de places qu'il faudrait créé
par contre je pense qu'il faudrait une
vigilance particulière en effet à la
rotation des familles qui sont déjà sur
les aires d'accueil
c'est une question qui m'avait été posée
en effet par les gens du voyage avec qui
j'ai discuté je pense que ça mériterait
aussi réflexions de voir un peu les taux
de rotation parce que si on retrouve
souvent les mêmes familles qui viennent
du coup voilà donc en plus ce sont des
populations qui sont itinérantes ou qui
sont loués à bouger c est donc à ce
titre là il conviendrait de s'y pencher
peut-être même avant de penser à en
créer de nouvelles chaises musicales
avec les voyageurs mais c'est leur
demande moi j'essaie les demandes qui
m'ont fait personnellement quand je dis
ce que tu as vécu c'est que il se
plaignait de voir tout le temps les
mêmes familles s'installer dans les
aires d'accueil et donc du coup ils
pouvaient pas s'installer dont il
s'occupe ils occupent des terrains de
manière illégale
donc je pense qu'il ya quelque chose à
un curseur a trouvé son oeuvre à ce
niveau là je connais pas suffisamment le
dossier ce que c'est pas ma délégation
mais maintenant que je suis concernée je
vais regarder de plus près cette
émission touche à sa fin merci en tout
cas tous les trois d'avoir les présents
merci d'avoir suivi cette fuite des
banques se retrouvent mercredi prochain
pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]